welcome back to cbs this morning tens of
millions of americans
will drive or fly for the thanksgiving
holiday despite the pandemic
according to aaa cbs news has learned
the tsa expects to screen more than 6
million people in the days ahead
that's leading the concerns about an
even bigger surge
in the virus nationwide chris van cleave
reports now on how families
are responding a socially distant
thanksgiving came early for laura
douglas's family
celebrating outside in october now the
numbers are really rising
very very sharply and even just having
it this coming weekend i think we would
have felt very threatened
about getting together there were fewer
guests visiting family were spaced apart
at separate tables
and masks were worn it allowed the
family to be together
but not too close together my mother is
a cancer patient
so she's at high risk and we knew that
there would be no way to spend time with
my parents
if we didn't figure out something that
was very very different
this year will be different aaa's newly
released thanksgiving travel forecast
expects
up to 50 million will travel down at
least 10 percent from last year
95 percent will drive as people opt for
last minute trips and stay closer to
home
right now it's really determining the
factor people decide to go
or stay are the number of coveted cases
as they increase
but also looking at state restrictions
aaa believes those flying will drop
nearly 48 percent
but airlines are gearing up for their
busiest stretch since the start of the
pandemic
this travel holiday comes as the cdc
warns even small household gatherings
are an important contributor to the rise
in covet 19 cases
50 million people hitting the road
sounds like reason for concern doesn't
it
it's a big concern because again when
people
mix from higher prevalence of covet to
lower
you end up raising the level at the low
covered places
former cdc director dr thomas frieden
unfortunately
because so many people may get together
during thanksgiving
at a time when covet rates are so high
we might see explosive spread
through the month of december and the
december holidays would become
a very unmerry christmas
we know millions of people are going to
gather for thanksgiving the cdc is
urging people to keep those gatherings
small to your immediate household or a
small group of close contacts ideally
who live in the same area you do the cdc
also recommends keeping a mask on when
you're not eating
trying to be outdoors if possible if
you're inside open as many windows as
you can to increase ventilation
and stay out of tight or cramped spaces
and for many of us that means
staying out of the kitchen gail well you
have to worry about me being in the
kitchen
but i do think it's very important to
keep emphasizing
the advice that you're giving us chris
van cleave all the experts say the
safest way to travel is by car
with people that you know but i want to
take a minute to talk about
air travel can you talk about the safety
of air travel these days because a lot
of people will be traveling
even though you're told stay home but
what about the safety of air travel
is it okay absolutely we've seen
a growing number of studies come out in
the last month or so that reinforce
that between the mass mandates that the
airlines are
enforcing and the ventilation systems on
board they have a hospital grade hepa
filter and the way that they move air
refreshing
cabin air every two to three minutes
that the risk of spread
is is really relatively low so
i mean keep in mind you are getting into
a metal tube with other people
but uh research continues to show that
it is a low risk effort from at least
from the gate to the gate
the places where you might run into risk
is if you get too
you know if you let your guard down in
the uber on the way to the airport or
while you're at the airport or as you're
getting to your destination after you
get off the plane
so you have to look at it as a as a
whole process
where you're on guard the entire time
but it appears based on the research we
keep seeing
that the uh gate to gate experience if
you will on board the plane
is relatively low risk all right got it
chris vancleave thank you very much
the most important thing you can have in
your arsenal these days is a mask
we can all get one of those a variety of
price ranges
thanks again chris chris